bonjour
la tête pour le monde s'amuse alors je
ne veux pas vous attrister puisque c'est
triste avec l'épisode du départ d'élise
a
non
la question des annonceurs gago ce n'est
pas elisa mai
jane en enchaînant les copines pas grave
on one
[Applaudissements]
elise ans
eli va les assauts d'un coup elise en
élisant
ça chez moi d en france bien des ondes
délicat dans
le chante du golo cheveux lisses
des bisous les assauts des mois ont
coûté et
cherche moi des poufs c'est moi
quelques mauvaises créances
thomas
une carte
deux ans
lisa
autant s'en fout et lillois
elisa
que toi - août et 20 ans et 40
si tu crois que ça
tous
alors
à l'isard
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et ça
elisor
tout
moi beaucoup qu'élise
amusant
recherche au moins en france bien
[Musique]
glos
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
un sous le tapis
duluc recon ou du cancer
il
depuis j'ai eu les deux cas son credo
[Musique]
sous le soleil
exactement juste en dessous
dans quai
dans quels districts c'était tout bord
de la mer
depuis
g
[Musique]
il y est là qu est exécuté coûté porte
sous le soleil exactement
custodio
oui
ce
au mexique
m
[Musique]
km
l argile
sous le par pour tous celui du sénat
j'aime tout le monde
juste en dessous
[Musique]
c'est sûr
nautique
[Musique]
que je
c'est
les yeux ouverts et pourtant si
terry sous
et que je te donne
[Musique]
pour tous exactement
juste en dessous
[Musique]
gainsbourg et son gainsbourg ont pris la
fuite
[Musique]
de leur lit par le hublot
il regarde
[Musique]
il sert
il attendait
c'est dur rentrent ils vaincront les
maléfices
je sais qu'un souhait sans de 10 60
oui
[Musique]
gainsbourg et son quel sport
rejoindre
ils sont laissés derrière
celle ci
il sert mais la traversée durera tout
q les yeux
jusqu'en suisse de 17 68
sinon
[Musique]
6ème et la traversée
du rock
quel prix
celui-ci
72 60
[Applaudissements]
sans moi
qui veut
[Musique]
à
2 millions
[Musique]
m
d'idées ou des chansons ont prouvé que
vous ne recherchez pas le succès et s'il
vient à vous ce n'est pas de votre fait
d'autre part vous parlez souvent
d'argent de vente de rentabilité de
chansons qui marche qui ne marche pas
c'est pas pour une contradiction ce qui
prouve que je n'ai pas signé si j'étais
comme ça sociaux sur l'argent je ferai
beaucoup un chiffre d'affaires du plus
fort j'écrirai pour les jeunes eux ils
revendaient qui sont ce qu'ils sont
c'est l'idée françois mathieu le jeu
mais du bon matériel et l'immatériel
pour les vendeurs et s'achèveront pour
les contrer c'est pas un peu déprimant
gmx énorme ici c'est déprimant c'est
pour ça je ne me fais pas vous ne l'avez
encore jamais entendu
peut-être vous ne l'entendrez jamais
plus alors autant en profiter tout de
suite c'est une chanson inédite
elle s'appelle la noyer
[Musique]
tous
dans l'ain
à
deby
/
marie
vient du souvenir et vous
moins grand sur la vie
le jeu de cry 2
venir
m
lente mentions
t'éloigner eux dorment à l'ours est
perdu
je
un peu
je te regarde un viol
tu es un peu
du
dans un an
tentures
non seulement le lait
vends mon
faux
lancker que rond
on se tue 10
youtube
le temps
deux cas le chant la figure
dedans
où ça
le taux des figures
la honte guerre tue
n'est plus
pour
chien tu vu
ouvrir
mais je reste ton esclave fond
dans le
ruisseau tour
l'oci venir s'avère tout
le seo
l'oubli
non
[Musique]
jamais
je
[Musique]
vous parlez de chansons populaires fait
sens pour vous les critères de la
chanson populaire
on a des sorciers qui avec les jets dans
la jungle de nouvelle guinée
[Musique]
ça l'histoire 2010
ça nous
[Musique]
jamais pris dans ce mois
ça bouge toi
et c'est
[Musique]
melty
mais elle en avait
[Musique]
mais ses jours étaient
quatorze autres
et m
[Musique]
titeuf
une inde europe
car ça
et si délicieux ans
jeunes etc
et qu'un instant nous
[Musique]
en 2010
aimable petit crâne
tu étais conditions
ciné
[Musique]
son
ça n'a quand même pas été
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je suis venu te dire
que je mens était la bonne
je
[Musique]
dissidia vers les deux
je suis venu te dire
souvient de jose e
têtu
où
[Musique]
je suis foutu
ce que
des adieux
je suis heureux élus
j'te dis
oui
suite
je m'en vais
des sanglots longs
[Musique]
m
bon
je suis venu te dire
tu te souviens des jo danseurs
et tu pleures
tu sembles type d'humour
quelle semaine
des adieux âge
souvent
2 bien que je mens
car tout
je suis venu te dire que je m'en veux
[Musique]
je
comme dit si bien à verdun
[Musique]
je suis venu te dire
tutti un bijou lancé
et tu peux
tous font que tu es
[Musique]
d azur
je suis heureux
tu te dis toujours
et je t'aime
je suis
te dis
des sanglots longs
changer
[Musique]
c'est bien
en
[Musique]
je suis
sous des jours heureux des tueurs
tu sembles titre
que cela
des hadj
et je suis au regret je te dire bonjour
[Musique]
e
[Applaudissements]
tu n'es pas le premier breton qui se
meurt talk
la bouche ouverte devant trônait
les yeux qu'en dépit de l'autre
je ne suis pas le premier wallon qui
trêve dans un ciel trop bleu éclaté sous
les coups des pins d'un petit garçon aux
yeux bleus
tu n'y pas le prix michel qui frissonne
devant ma porte
m
réduits
elle a premier kit
dans les corps de ceux ci musée
je ne suis par le premier garçon
à qui tu dis c'est terminé
mais si ça peut te consoler
non ça n'arrive pas seulement belles
toiles ce que je viens de lui chanter
d'autres mondes
[Musique]
tu n'es pas le premier mouton
que les loups gris on dévore
dans une forêt sans abri
à un hiver froid sans pitié
tu n'es pas de trop bien marrant a pas
donné de l'oci
[Musique]
je n'y étais pas
oui tu n'es pas le premier qui gnole qui
rappe son heavy de grisou et queues de
crevettes fouettard un envoi par
sectionné très tôt
tu n'es pas le premier oiseau qui s'est
associé dans sa classe
donné par le premier
[Musique]
je ne veux plus tourner départ
si ça peut te consoler
ça n'arrive pas seulement à
ce que je viens de chanter d'autres me
l'ont dit autrefois
tu n'es pas la première guitare dont les
cordes se sont repris par le premier
garçon
à qui tu dis c'est terminé
mais si ça peut nous consoler au monde
ça n'arrive pas qu'à moi c'est que je
viens mais tout comme me l'ont dit
[Musique]
oh
c'est extraordinaire bravo
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
j'ai le grand plaisir après de longs
mois d'absence à la télévision de vous
présenter un très très grand poète
français un garçon merveilleux dans la
poésie vit au rythme de notre temps
serge gainsbourg
[Applaudissements]
omar sy dont le tigre heure chacun
[Musique]
c'est plus
je peux
[Musique]
le pas
à vélo
c'est à toi
là
[Musique]
i
oh
la peau
voilà
[Musique]
là
m
et
[Musique]
oh
alou nouveau
à vélo
c'est pour
et
c'est
[Musique]
on
oh
la sainteté
et
[Musique]
ne pas
là
les choses
[Musique]
je
merci c'est un battant
sa grand music hall parisien de la rive
gauche serge gainsbourg présentait en
fakir un numéro de télépathie et
exceptionnellement ce soir pour musique
en music
nous allons reconstituer ce numéro est
avec la gentillesse de serge gainsbourg
nous allons tenter de faire d'autres
numéros de télépathie
serge venu gagner ce podium nous allons
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je suis
c'est vrai un seul défaut
c'est tout bon
moi tu vas
une vie de galères et 1
et quand je sors avec il regarde c'est
toujours un grand gars
tous mes amis leçon
on est star très souvent
chevigny ce bandit
chaussures des épées
avec d'italie
et puis chants pour kléber plus un rugby
audois
debiais parfait il a des jambes le
tournoi est très jolie petite balade
vélo cinéma
ward et six mois
pour voir et whisky à gogo j'ai pas mal
au foie gras cents 200
je
dr mois valait bouchehr depuis cette
date
l'appel basbug
diop
je fais du chemin
tous les matins
car j'adore la de l'odeur du crottin je
ne fréquente que des larmes
prenons comme des fous
paiement
ah bon
et quand je parle
on sait tout est vrai
on se réunit
les avaient tous l'air peu d
pour faire d'esprit y aller que 15 ans
des deux salles et du caire envers mange
à la petite cuillère
pardon
je vous dis à moi
on peut rêver du plus bas j'avais le
privé est savamment juillet
je
retournez l'autre côté ce n'est plus par
an
g
[Musique]
in an en java
je passe le moins d'eau procureur
c'est parler
si les aigles
delon l'esm
encore plus fou tout à l'heure
les gants chaussures décor
je souhaite
j'ai
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
sur et bien ce soir à musicale musique
nous allons nous promener dans l'oeuvre
poétique d'un compositeur importants
d'impôts est authentique et d'un ami et
d'un ami ce qui est bien agréable et à
l'énoncé de son nom
tout ce que la chanson française compte
de formidables a répondu présent alors
ce soir avec la l'avant-garde de la
chanson française autour de lui avec
vous avec nous
nous accueillons serge gainsbourg avec
une chanson de ses débuts le poinçonneur
des lilas serge gainsbourg
[Musique]
le gars qu'on croise et qu'on ne regarde
pas y a pas de soleil sous la terre
drôle de croisière
tu es notre bilan reste les extraits du
reader's digest et dans ce bouquin il ya
écrit que des cas cela coule douce berry
pendant ce temps que je fais le soir
au fond de la cave
pareil il ya moins de sot métier moi je
fais des tournants des billets
je fais tout des petits trous ou encore
les petits trous des p'tits trous des
p'tits trous toujours et petits trous
les trous de seconde classe
des trous toutes premières places je
vais les trous des p'tits trous encore
les petits trous des p'tits trous des
p'tits trous toujours les petites roues
est petit on les petits trous des p'tits
trous des p'tits trous
une saveur des lilas pour invalides
changer opéra je vis au coeur de la
lettre
j'ai dans la tête être un carnaval
british emmène jusqu'en mongolie
et souvent ciel de faïence genevois
brillé que les correspondances
parfois je rêve
je divague je vois les vagues
et dans la brume au bout du quai
joignent batum chercher
pour sortir de ce trou je fais les trous
des p'tits trous des p'tits trous
toujours les petits trous mais le pathos
bayonne et je vois je déraille
et je reste dans mon trou
tous les petites routes
[Musique]
suite à ces métiers direct par le manoir
j'en ai marre j'en ai ma claque de ce
prix
d'ailleurs laissé ma casquette au
vestiaire
un jour viendra j'en suis sûr j'pourrais
m'évader nature je partirai sur en route
et coûte que coûte dessine moi il n'est
plus temps je partirai les filles
novembre
je fais des trous des p'tits trous quand
des petits trous des p'tits trous des
p'tits trous touche au même titre
diack quattre distingue de quoi faire un
trou à un titre ou un
un petit trou noir un dernier petit
rayon mais pas vraiment trouvé jean
thouard effet parlé trop vite jamais
troublé petits trous le petit route
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
serge gainsbourg gainsbourg qui donne
obstant une entorse et ça arrive a tenu
ce soir a assuré ce music musique et je
l'en remercie
ça
serge gainsbourg l'eau à la bouche
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
écoute pavois et toutes parts hier
écoute mon père
pas le sautoir
le temps
quand
je te veut confiante je te sens captive
je te dossier qui
je
en
[Musique]
je
ce troc des courants porter dans le lit
du torrent et dans le bien que tu veux
bien
quittons le niveau pas ton gamin
je peux prendre doucement
de quoi tu pleures
le train je tente et reçoit par
en
loi à la gauche 7 8 de moins bien
oui je sais
pour que tu ne t'es pas
je veux
vous
[Musique]
c'est la jeunesse
parce que les auteurs compositeurs fond
si leurs chansons et les chante
alors après le grand succès de sex and
sun il va nous chanter sous ça lui va
très bien
mr iceberg
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
myst iceberg assuré pour marc une petite
boucle d'or qu i sur les peaux sud une
console était piste iceberg au sol et
bloquent tout secoué la fille qui dore
puy news les beaux sud comme à
l'habitude mist
[Musique]
liszt sbk sur les bancs petite fille un
cola et sur les baux sud comme
internet est un iceberg au sol et bon
ordre pour rayer sans disque d'or et 100
et pau sud est ce qui se fait de
mystères de l'amour hommes sur leur
liste avec est allé ce bug est à dix
buts fillon 6
[Musique]
est iceberg à sur les bunds une petite
bille encore et sur les peaux sud un peu
de lassitude piste iceberg au sol est
plein pour l'ufr voir qu'il est mort une
hausse des baux sud c'est sont
[Musique]
est un esb et m me là
les petites filles ont su
[Musique]
m
allez
[Musique]
à
et tu étais parti comptant presque trois
ans trois ans il s'est passé des choses
2 j'ai fait un disque aux pour rigoler
et essex m
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c
cette saison le soleil nous ceni 18-12
ce temps le débit serait menacé
c est
c'est ça
[Musique]
toi petit tuer
le soleil moussanais
[Musique]
surexcité du sein de kelly
ça
toi petit c'est sûr tu es magique
le programme maintenant
[Applaudissements]
voir recevoir un auteur compositeur qui
fait les gens sont si belles depuis si
longtemps
ce que c'est ainsi tu peux plus y croire
on se retrouve en 1999 clôture à 20 ans
de métier moi j'allais six pièces
étaient d'accord bon mais il ya une
différence entre nous c'est quoi ça
s'écrit aujourd'hui un point commun ya
un point commun il ya une différence
moi j'ai jamais défense gamin sauvé
quand même
j'étais des margines avec lui et je vois
ici copie night 1964 puis de l'an 60 kw
à 5 4 65 euros vision petit à petit et
la gt est né pour tous ont trouvé un
toit et une est plus original c'est plus
un marginal mais c'est comment dire quoi
c'est avec une écoute polie d'accord
j'écoutais déjà beaucoup les jeux donner
le plus
plus je lis couplet ah oui j'ai choisi
le meilleur ami pleurer je te résiste tu
sais pourquoi je sais bien ce que je vis
tout seul
et toi t'en j'irai chez toi puisque
c'est comme ça rien que ma cassette est
petit ce que tu veux boire
plus écouter les hommes
ça
moi ce jeu suivant
[Musique]
deux toi bien entendu dans la bouche de
oui moi c'était plus romantiques la
rencontre que j'ai eue de france parce
que je lui ai écrit un texte que j'avais
envie qu'elle qu'elle dise
puis il ya tellement cru finalement
s'appeler la déclaration
différence avec la vie privée aussi
quand je suis seul que je peux rêver
[Musique]
je rêve que je suis dans tes bras
rêve que je te fais tout bas
[Musique]
une déclaration de doha est autre chose
évidemment ma déclaration qu en justice
elle que je peux
t
que tu es la tourelle mois
[Musique]
imaginez
où
rassure
[Musique]
ma déclaration
juste deux ou trois mots les maux
je suis
pour te parler de nous
ou trois mots de tous les jours c'est
tout
quand je suis seul que je peux
je rêve que je suis un débat qui arrive
dans l'artois je vais te met bas j'ai
skié fait cette fois une déclaration des
crachats
ma des classes
vous
je ne sais jamais si je suis maintenant
ça c'est aulas lors qu ici mais moi j'ai
les babys peuvent se sont gênés de
photos déjà quand elle avait 14 à18 un
joli teint une relique ayala dans le
détail
passage une bible peut ignorer les
dangers que représentent les libertés je
dois d'acteurs les menaces de guerre eux
semblent se préciser
ça va changer à cet instant baby tu le
sais où tous les seuls
ils vont seul
elle que partir la tête
la vraie philosophie n'est pas le siffle
le sang les versets chante dans ce corps
de repères
et pape
devait jamais
je veux
chantant sous peu
comme si tu m'as vu
m
au petit matin
d'état
tu
ce festival est pessimiste et va lancer
mais c'était un vrai test donc tu lui as
pas écrit des chansons que j'en ai
toujours je peux être assassiné par la
société consommer un peu elle a balancé
permanence a rigolé sec que chacun se
mette à chanter en dérivant dit
que chacun se laisse emporter eric
chacun contre l'eau tous élèves
seul celui de blanche pour l'autre en
lacets
un autre groupe important dit elle
10 on est trop faible pour s'entretuer
[Musique]
on est trop seul pour seul été
la suite on est trop mal qu'on s'en
rajouter
on est trop rien pour se déchirer
[Musique]
les uns les autres vivent ici
et posons nous
owens chez elle aux armées c'était
renault bouclier dit très content des
doigts et fera policiers
c'est efficace des gentils ou méchants
issus est simple mare alors d'abord
c'est une chanson que dont tommy
d'où france absolument battre absolument
rien contre et les sucettes
sucette
les
6e temps
huit années
dota ses baisers un goût anisé
lorsque le sucre
je
parfait mer
cool dans la
jeudi
elle est ou pas
un délire là le pont génial auquel que
penny
parmi la csu cette année 600 la couleur
de ses yeux la couleur des jours heureux
à la ce point rien compris à ce texte et
à dia quelqu'un ces derniers temps
pourquoi qui lui demandait pourquoi
changer pas dit c'est mon âge enfin si
la chanson géniale qu'il a fait le plus
de mal videmment par lolita
c'est simple et c'est romantique la lune
en secret
bien
je t'emmène
les nuages triste vont s'amuser encore
des rimes en indien vient
je t'emmène
le sol est le soir se reposer j'ai
tellement fermé les yeux
j'ai tellement rêver
j'y suis arrivé
eh bien
je t'emmène
derrière le miroir l'autre t
ja
je m'en vais
payer
pays j'ai fait
j'ai tellement fermé
j'ai tellement rêver
j'y suis arrivé
ouvrir à la réalité
merriman moi je vais te donner une leçon
de prosodie moi je prenais toujours
déprimant axes x c'est à dire c'est
beaucoup plus difficile
si j'ai pas d'idée j'ai pas aimé et le
motoriste et la soude qu'un prétexte je
ne veux
avoir des réflexes mal
françois sa forme il faut que tu
m'expliques un peu
en te dire adieu
sous aucun prétexte je ne
devant toi sur exposé
monsieur
20 kleenex je saurai mieux non
jeudi 28 e
je mise à l'index gens
tony blanche
eric de françoise en plus
x
des applications vaudrait mieux
c'est beau
j'arrive pas critiquer je le sens pas
peut pas les noms mais françois c'est la
star qui veut pas être star et c'est
vraiment il y interprète fantastique
alors moi j'ai bêtement suivi j'ai aussi
fait une chanson pour françoise je sache
4e j
très juste fait croire que tu m'aimes
été soulevée
me gêne
puis coup jusqu'à perdre haleine
[Musique]
si tu crois jeu
et si ce jour
ces chemins de mai
il y a
si tu crois jeu
le
aussi
un problème
miku jusqu'à terre
ja
la passion j'ai suffisament au mieux
dans la ville où l'attaqué ouais à 22
cynique c'est ça que que devenir cinoque
mexique parce que tu es quelqu'un de
très froid non c'est pas ça vient
philosophe allemand s'est peu de
championnat mais qui à dix les animaux à
sang froid du venin bon alors un
précepteur vos apports s'agit plus qu'à
écouter serge lui-même parce que les
auteurs compositeurs fond si leurs
chansons et les chante
alors après le grand succès de sixun
ivan chanter tout ça lui va très bien
mr iceberg
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
mais déjà m
j'avoue j'en ai bavé pas vous mon amour
[Musique]
mandat voire vous prend de vous mon
le
pour
en sont là
tous
[Musique]
2 millions
le temps
jean
[Musique]
à votre avis cave en vue de l'amour
nous à moi
[Musique]
le
je
on
[Musique]
tous genres
où sont ils
[Musique]
je veux
vie de bois
[Musique]
des fleurs
son
bonjour
[Musique]
août
je songe
je
sans tarder
le chien
mais c'est vous qui l'avez voulu
mon
son
les hommes
[Musique]
chan
soit
chut
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
l'accord jour de gloire mais déclarent
[Musique]
les tendeurs était défense
centre
[Musique]
ça serge
chiche
[Musique]
très content je les entends
derrière ce serait bien j'avais toujours
ton copain me présenter ma femme était
partie avec deux parties
[Musique]
je te su tenir dans l'aip
mais j'ai senti refusé d'être témoin
[Musique]
j'ai dit mon vieil cana
j'avoue j'en ai bavé ma voix
en un mot enfin d'avoir eu vent de vous
mon amour
pollen en dansant
nous
do you le ton change
à votre avis qu'avons nous vu de l'avis
de vous avoir m'avait zélande
[Musique]
danse en mangeant
nous
sont hélas avril en vain à la bourre
j'avais envie de voir en bout ce plan -
plein
au fond on dans son genre
[Musique]
le temps
chambre
il vaut d'être vécue
120 nous c'est vous qui l'avez vous lu
mon amour
[Musique]
dans 100 g
nous nous souvenions vieux temps
chaque sou
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
j'ai remarqué que je ne sais pas à quoi
l'a invité mais que vous répétez de plus
en plus la même phrase dans vos chansons
alors je me suis dit ou bien il est en
panne d'inspiration ou bien ils aiment
de plus en plus ce qu'il fait je ne sais
pas quelle interprétation branger aulas
donc je veux dire quand vous avez un
leit motiv un oui c'est pas un refrain
je veux dire c'est quelque chose que
vous pouvez répéter 24 30 ou prendre
deux fois les autres comme les autres
noms mais le public lui ni à oui oui
mais vous pensez à main pour que le
public comprenne à une fonction
on va essayer
[Musique]
on retourne aux 15,3 en découlent
à
cloutier
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
où
[Musique]
gérant
c'est
[Musique]
avec
bové
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
la donne
gala
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
d'abord je veux avec ma langue
natal la toux
devinez
dans ce pays
catoire a déjà
des habitants bien aux flux et des
reflux des marées
ah oui
le coup
je pense à toi en tant que simple elle
at elle enfin un gars de l'est
j'ai tout seul
c
je vais m'y attarder
[Musique]
je vais
on
oui
il est temps de passer aux choses
[Musique]
ma poupée est jolie
je
on omet
[Musique]
il
lemay
[Musique]
je me souviens aux griffes de
adam de dentelle
je lis cool
comme la rue merlet le centre
nommé
je
leduc triple crown pour gérer
du simple et émouvant
le moment dix ans où je te dirais les
goûts
plus abominables
demain
m
un seul
en a
entre eux
enfin
[Applaudissements]
non
oui
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
vous êtes
et quand les maladies envie vraiment
voilà un enchaînement qui est quand même
assez royal s'était pas épatant maïween
donc ça rassure tout de suite c'est une
addition de l'hérault
[Musique]
mon petit fils
ça
sûrement des mélanges
[Musique]
oh
destiny
douceur monstreux canton
[Musique]
d où ma beauté
tv
plot tout le monde
[Musique]
s'il tue
aussi peu juste
lot de règles tue et tout ce bonheur
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il est dans ta beauté je vous devais me
ton regard mais trans une perceuse tous
les charmes de
dans ce
[Musique]
tu veux
une extrême orient ligue 1
au mali des mères
dans ta bonté je vous devez nord
en tout regain montrant spence tous les
chats paire solide
m
non
tu veux tu est extrêmement court
[Musique]
un chemin
le soir
et tu as vu il ya les filles
bon alors il vulgaire vous rester là et
nous allons écouter maintenant serge
gainsbourg est retrouvée après face à
france
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
soir que dans le bon sens g t au non
plus en dieu
la boule au ventre était le mieux qu'une
immense public
[Musique]
je me baisse
baez
jeudi
donc sur le trop tard je recherchais
samantha
[Musique]
il est évident que c'était mal barré
pour moi
[Musique]
mais
c'était de police plaque de papier le
stand
un cycle positif pour moi black honneurs
du grand défi
[Musique]
x
gaucho de veste
ben ouais
[Musique]
rocheleau baisse
berne berne
[Musique]
à
mr
ces mesures monnaie retrouver ça va
[Musique]
m
quand
[Musique]
ah ah
[Applaudissements]